[Applause]
thank you so much for being here thank
you thank you so much
he just he gets mad we're trying to do
the show he gets mad well what a
wonderful holiday saint patrick's day
huh
i've seen people wear every kind of
thing on the same page i've never seen
i'm trying to put the sex back in the st
patrick's day
this is a mongolian bush tiger
and uh
and you can uh you can tell it's a boy
he's got a huge strip sack
let me ask you something where did you
where did you learn
what did you learn about st patrick's
day thank you
where did you
you know like this and they're always
like
oh my god
do you guys have hot chocolate where are
you going wait what are you doing
what have you done
just stop it that's my new character
[Applause]
you got awarded a star on the hollywood
walk of fame and the one thing i thought
of as you know as i looked out you know
i've got my mom and my dad i've got my
kids my wife friends and family
i couldn't help but think
gosh i'm
i'm so much better than you
i had a very 1950s approach to the birth
of my child yeah
i stayed in the waiting room and
i said any news yet
what's the word
no i was i was in there i was in the
delivery room did you read the video
camera thing i didn't do the video
camera my wife would have killed me yeah
you don't want to show that to people
video camera in her crotch
if i was on a desert island and i had a
choice between eating a wall burger and
a raw dead fish
i would eat the dead fish
[Applause]
no
is it a cockatoo it looks a little like
a cockatoo you're so dirty
immediately gotta
go for the joke and i didn't go you know
would it help if i told you yes it's a
cockatoo okay
and here's a funny one conan he's got a
emily blunt emily blind salmon
[Applause]
[Music]
the
[Music]
where did she come from
i oh
all right what is magnus up to how old
is he nine he's nine years old i think
he's the same age as your barry just
turned ten okay yeah and is he is he
playing sports soccer and the like he
plays some tennis played some baseball
skiing and stuff like that how's his
commitment level
[Laughter]
well i'm just curious he's i'm just
curious
all right
it's unlikely that he'll be considered
for the heisman trophy
because we have the same issue with matt
now magnus is a decent soccer player
he's got some some good footwork he's on
like a little all-star team great he's
doing really well
but he doesn't like to run
[Laughter]
and and and soccer is a game where you
have to run a lot that's what i've heard
and uh so we we talk about
the lack of effort sometimes that
a ball could be
four feet in front and uh it's as if he
doesn't even know it exists
and so i've been on the road a bunch
promoting the movie and i was checking
him up with my wife about
you know how was that they had a playoff
game and they lost and
it was in the rain and
not a lot of effort and
and it's not that we want him to be a
professional athlete but you know try
your best
so i was discussing it with a friend and
he said well you know my kids i gave him
the go big or go home speech
so i said viv it might be time to give
him the go big or go home speech uh
so she said i'm gonna do it and uh
she started talking to him and said you
know you really have some talent and
that's that's we want you to do your
best and
so uh
you know next game you know there's a
saying go big or go home and he listened
and he took it all in he's like so so
next week what do you think you're going
to do he's like
i'm going to go big
but right now i really want to go home
i'm cold
it's raining
and i want to go home
and i don't think he went big in the
next game i think he just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
got some reading material for you
a bunch of playboys from the 70s these
are
yeah these are real
these are vintage 1970s playboys yeah
take a look in there
you're not gonna find anything shaved in
there my friend
all right look at that look at that
little outfit i am ready to call offside
at any time
and you're just going fist fists but i
pulled the socks up and uh i usually get
through half a game before
before one of the kids on on an opposing
team is like
are you the elf
what about something about the the
middle son
uh the middle son is um uh matthias he's
um
he's already uh a looker and he knows it
he knows it uh he um
i overheard him talking to a little
friend the other day
saying uh doing this to him
[Laughter]
and the other boy said why are you doing
that
and
he said this is how you get girls
how did it feel to shave it off was it a
weird experience it's a strange because
if you've had a mustache for three
months you get used to looking
looking at that and and
when i finally shaved it i i literally
thought i looked better with a mustache
i had
an upper lip phobia all of a sudden i
was panicking
did you order a mustache i never had a
mustache actually or a goatee
no i should think about it i should
think about it
you're so old when you were a kid
rainbows were black and white
that doesn't sound very original
invited to read the grinch how the
grinch stole christmas that's is that a
tradition they read that every year for
the kids i don't know
i don't know uh
but they asked me
in this one year uh this last year and
uh and we asked if we could obviously
bring of course the boys and uh and we
got there
and they said here's the map room here's
where your boys can hang out go where
are the other kids they're like there
aren't any kids
uh i said okay but i'm reading the
grinch that's right you're just reading
it to 200 adults
so
that doesn't seem right it didn't seem
yeah so i had to read the grinch to
the white the basically the cabinet and
the executive staff
and
so i i i
and it was a surprise yeah absolutely
you thought it was going to go a whole
different way i thought it was going to
go a whole different way i thought it
was going to at least there'd be
children at my feet
and i'm just looking out at secretary of
defense robert gates yeah
and and so i i assumed i thought well i
got to change gears here they're
probably going to want me to make it
funny i would think
you know i walk up there and i'm reading
the grinch so the only thing i could
think of was to read it
as as former president bush um
well that's
that's good thinking
[Applause]
so i
started by saying uh uh this is uh
i'm about to read the grinch you stole
christmas it's uh
dr seuss is one of my favorite books
uh even though he can and he is known as
getting tongue twistery at times
um
but it's a good piece of literature you
know
and uh
[Applause]
now keep in mind a grinch is a fictional
character
we've researched this the grinch is not
for real okay
but the whos the whos they they do live
in a small village in macedonia
they're good people
cindy luhu
um
now uh
what is that
haven't you ever seen a chicken
before i i believe this show is seen in
england is that correct yeah yeah and i
would i would love to give the royal
couple uh my greeting
uh if i could please go right into since
i won't be there go right ahead please i
know they would appreciate it
[Applause]
oh that's very nice
very nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait a minute
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a little bernie frank thing going on
there
[Music]